et on en parlait en début d'émission les
enfants de la terre c'est une
association yvinoise qui tente de venir
en aide à certains enfants confrontés à
des situations d'urgence Nathalie Noah
donc vous êtes en plateau avec nous pour
nous en parler vendredi dernier donc
vous avez organisé ce tournoi de golf
caritatif qui s'est bien déroulé ce que
vous avez atteint justement vous
objectives en termes de dons écoutez oui
nous avons récolté pour cette journée
quasiment 16000 euros
donc c'est très bien ça va pouvoir nous
aider à continuer nos actions et ça
dépasse les objectifs que vous étiez
fixés un petit peu un petit peu en tout
cas c'était un bon c'était un bon
tournoi les gens répondent présents donc
c'était tout allait très bien et alors
pour présenter un petit peu aussi votre
votre association puisque l'été
spectateur ne la connaissent pas
forcément donc elle a été créée en 1988
par Marie-Claire votre mère et votre
frère Yannick est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi ils ont eu aussi ce projet
commun et envie d'aider les enfants mais
je pense que déjà on a vécu très peu de
temps au Cameroun et maman avait une
école maternelle et aimait beaucoup les
enfants et en fait quand elle est
rentrée en France elle s'ennuie un petit
peu elle a très bien dans une autre
association et puis un jour il s'est dit
mais pourquoi pas monter notre
association et c'est comme ça qu'on a
commencé avec nos maisons tendresse on
accueille des enfants on en reparlera
justement tout de suite vous avez des
objectifs multiples que vous intervenez
notamment dans la prévention à la
délinquance vous accompagner aussi les
enfants qui sont hospitalisés ou malades
quels sont finalement vos périmètres
d'action puisque j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a énormément de choses que vous
effectuez en fait au départ à la base
c'était c'était les maisons tendresse on
avait des enfants et pendant toutes les
périodes de vacances scolaires on
accueilli des enfants en difficulté
sociale ou économique et après maman ça
a grandi un petit peu on a commencé à
aider beaucoup les hôpitaux donc on est
beaucoup des hôpitaux donc on a beaucoup
de demandes d'aide parce que les enfants
qui sont hospitalisés très longtemps
souvent les parents n'arrivent pas soit
se loger à côté de l'hôpital soit à
payer le matériel donc on les beaucoup
financièrement et comment est-ce qu'on
peut bénéficier des actions de
l'association ce qui a des critères
spécifiques ou une zone géographique
en général les enfants nous sont envoyés
par des assistantes sociales voilà qui
nous appellent au bureau et où les
écoles et on accueille tous les enfants
il y a pas de il y a pas de géolocaliser
bon bien sûr on est dans les Yvelines on
va pas faire venir des enfants de Lyon
mais disons que voilà autour de nous
Paris les Yvelines on prend beaucoup
d'enfants et vous parlez de d'urgence
d'urgence de situation d'urgence
qu'est-ce que c'est exactement comme des
enfants sont enlevés à leurs parents
quelquefois quelquefois il y a des voilà
des problèmes avec les parents soit ils
sont placés soit on les accueille dans
une maison Gabriel vous avez une
question la création de l'association
vous vous rendez compte que le besoin
s'accroît au niveau des enfants il y a
de plus en plus de besoins comment ça
fait 10 ans maintenant que j'ai repris
complètement l'association avant je
travaille avec maman mais que dans le
dans les spectacles et organisations de
d'événements pour gagner de l'argent
mais on a vu
on a senti après le covid qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes et que beaucoup de
beaucoup de demandes d'enfants voilà et
de maman aussi il y a beaucoup de
moments qui nous demandent aussi de
t'entendre on essaie d'emmener les
mamans avec leurs enfants pour essayer
de souffler un petit peu ça leur fait du
bien je pense que oui ça leur fait non
sincèrement ça fait beaucoup de bien
parce qu'on a que des bons retours et
notre association quand on accueille des
enfants dans cette maison c'est pas une
colonie on accueille 12 enfants on est
4-5 éducateurs c'est vraiment une petite
famille voilà donc ça se passe très bien
et combien de d'événements est-ce que
vous organisez chaque année ça dépend en
fonction de en général on fait le
trophée de golf quelques fois on fait le
foot on fait de la pétanque et après
pas forcément pas forcément si il y en a
qui veulent faire des événements pour
nous on dit oui malheureusement c'est
rare mais ça arrive
et alors du coup est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez à peu près combien d'enfants
ont pu ou de famille ont pu bénéficier
de l'association vous avez des chiffres
en tête depuis qu'on a commencé
on en a écouté je peux pas vous dire
puis qu'on a commencé ah non je peux pas
vous dire et alors
on en est de 200 250 mais depuis je sais
pas et à l'époque on avait plus de
maison là on en a moins parce qu'à
l'époque on avait 5 maisons on en a
gardé plus qu'une maintenant et vous
avez encore contact avec les premiers
enfants que vous avez accompagnés
la première petite fille qui s'appelait
Isis qui est arrivé à six mois qui avait
perdu ses parents et on est toujours en
contact avec elle on en a plein on en a
une bonne dizaine et on est très fiers
parce qu'ils sont ils étaient rien au
départ ils sont devenus journalistes on
a des acteurs on a des belles histoires
et c'est important de les voir évoluer
déjà pour nous parce que moi c'est un
sens à ce qu'on fait parce que c'est pas
toujours facile quand on accueille les
enfants on leur donne du bonheur de
l'amour en s'amuse il s'en vont et plus
rien donc on essaie d'avoir un suivi et
le plus beau des cadeaux c'est quand on
reçoit les lettres des enfants après ces
jours ça c'est très émouvant peut-être
en faire un livre avec tous les
souvenirs je pense qu'on pourrait écrire
je pense qu'on pourrait peut-être quand
je la retraite quand je prendrai ma
retraite pourquoi pas non c'est vrai
qu'on a des très belles histoires aux
enfants de la terre et ça fait du bien
de enfin nous on aime on aime donner
accompagner les enfants donc c'est c'est
parfait cette année vous avez des
prochaines actions qui sont prévues
normalement la pétanque et après dans
cette année normalement on part en
séjour là et en ces jours-là on part
très vite parce que tous les temps on
est en séjour donc on a pas d'autres
actions là de prévues